mon inconscient me disait pourquoi elle
et pas moi sacré
[Rires]
caractère sacré je sais pas en en
toutous les cas c'est mon
caractère c'est comme ça VO obstiné euh
ou ou c'était les criti c'était les
critiques que me faisait cette méchante
maîtresse d'école qui qui reste très
obsédante pour moi d'ailleurs et que
j'ai même cristallisé à travers cette
actrice à qui je demandais d'être la
plus monstrueuse possible quand elle
disait à ce gosse qu'il était
indécrotable moi P que vous disz votre
in oui mais c'est une façon de dire que
on peut toujours agir sur soi et avoir
la maîtrise de soi peut-être pas la
maîtrise mais en tous les cas
s'améliorer de façon à contribuer aussi
peut-être à améliorer le monde alors
merci beaucoup Richard Berry d'être
voilà ici ce soir parce que je sais que
vous n'aimez pas trop parler de vous
vous êtes assez discret Marie donc votre
sœur à qui vous avez fait ce don
d'organe nous rejoindra tout à l'heure
puisque vous avez accepté d'être réuni
aussi ici depuis cette double opération
alors pour vous c'est un geste d'amour
Richard Berry ou un vrai travail d'homme
c'est ce que dit votre ami et comédien
Patrick
Timsit j'ai été élevé dans cette culture
disons de la maladie si je peux dire de
ma sœur puisque elle a une maladie
génétique depuis la naissance et que
j'ai toujours su qu'elle était malade
j'ai toujours su qu'elle était en survie
et puis j'ai très tôt vu ma mère faire
le même geste parce qu'il faut pas
oublier que ma mère il y a il y a 33 ans
lui a déjà donné un rein c'était même
une pionnière en la matière puisqueil y
en avait eu très très peu auparavant des
donneurs vivants et donc je sais pas je
c'était naturel c'est ça que c'était
naturel quoi je veux dire je n'ai pas
c'est c'est c'est dans les deux années
qui ont précédé cette opération que j'ai
subi que j'ai finalement
euh pris le temps où j'étais obligé d'y
réfléchir vous pensiez que ça pouvait
arriver depuis toujours ou pour vous
elle votre sœur on lui demandera tout à
l'heure mais avez avis si je puis dire
le rein de votre mère ou ou je l'avais
non non je l'avais toujours imaginé
j'avais même d'ailleurs je me souviens
très très bien j'avais posé la question
à ma mère il y a y a il y a 33 ans
j'avais 18 ans ou 19 ans je lui avais
demandé pourquoi c'est toi et pas moi
elle m'avait expliqué que d'abord
c'était les parents siétait et puis que
moi il fallait que je garde la
possibilité d'aider un de mes enfants si
j'en avais plus tard qui serait
susceptible d'avoir une ce genre de
maladie donc comme ça n'a pas été le cas
je gardais cette cette fenêtre ouverte
en moi sur ce ce ce don éventuel alors
quelques mois seulement puisque c'était
le 21 juin après cette opération on est
quand même assez stupéfait de vous
retrouver dans une forme absolument
incroyable parce que c'est vrai que vous
avez une double actualité non seulement
on vous retrouve tous les soirs donc au
côté de Patrick teamsit dans une pièce
extrêmement drôle donc L'emmerdeur et
dans dans quelque chose d'assez physique
et en même temps en promotion de de ce
film dont on va parler qui fait écho à
votre propre histoire comment vous
trouvez l'énergie d'être de mener tout
ça de front là parce qu'on voit que vous
êtes vous vous sentez en forme je sais
pas je je ne trouve pas l'énergie je
l'ai je ne cherche rien du tout j'ai
j'ai je suis comme ça je c'est la preuve
aussi que donner un rein n'affecte en
rien la santé quand elle est bonne au
départ j'ai toujours aimé me sentir bien
dans mon corps j'ai toujours fait du
sport je bois pas trop d'alcool je je
voilà je me suis pas adonné à des
drogues jusqu'à présent donc voilà j'ai
cette chance c'est tout Richard vous
auriez pu un moment donné renoncer vous
avez douté vous avez eu peur ce qui
aurait été normal alors oui j'ai eu très
très peur franchement c'est très très
peur c'est une c'est un comptearbour qui
qui est extrêmement difficile à vivre
psychologiquement euh
mais je n'aurais jamais pu arrêter le
processus parce que je pense que je
n'aurais pas pu vivre avec
moi-même après avoir refusé de le faire
c'était impossible j'aurais jamais pu me
regarder dans la glace j'ai j'ai c'était
inconcevable de ne pas le faire donc il
fallait y aller c'est c'est comme ça
c'est comme quand on doit un jour aller
je sais pas passer son permis de
conduire il faut bien il faut y aller
faut faut bien y aller vous sentez
comment dire on dire en règle si je puis
dire avec vous-même ou en tout les cas
j'ai l'impression de faire aujourd'hui
tout ce que je peux pour ça alors que
peut-être
avant je je sentais qu'il me restait
quelque chose à faire quoi une dette oui
une espèce de dette ouis aussi fort que
ça oui mon inconscient me disait
pourquoi elle et pas moi donc il y a une
espèce de culpabilité qui est
omniprésente alors je disais hein en ce
moment vous nous entraînez dans deux
univers complètement différents une
comédie oui très drôle donc avec Patrick
Timsit L'emmerdeur et puis donc ce trème
film que vous réalisez la boîte noire
qui est formidablement réalisé et tout
aussi formidablement interprété par donc
on a vu José Garcia et Marion quetillard
donc Michel du CHA oui et beaucoup
d'autres comédiens voilà c'est carrément
un autre univers un polar psychologique
un triller oui on peut dire ouais ouais
avec une réalisation hyper hyper moderne
j'ai été au bout de
[Musique]
de ce que je ressens de ce que je suis
vraiment c'estàd que j'ai j'ai été au
bout de cet univers visuel parce
que je je je considère que dans le
cinéma la forme doit être le véhicule du
fond en confrontant donc l'univers réel
et l'univers mental qui est traité
différemment VO exactement c'estd qu'en
fin de compte moi je voulais qu' qu'on
rentre dans la boîte noire d'ailleurs on
y rentre dans le film mais je voulais
dire que quand on ouvre la boîte noire
c'est pour aller vers la lumière
justement donc à la suite d'un accident
le héros est à la recherche d'une partie
de sa mémoire et dans cette recherche de
mémoire quand il plonge dans son cerveau
donc dans sa fameuse boîte noire
ressurgit la mort accidentelle de son
frère quand il était petit son frère qui
n'a pas pu sauver donc c'est vrai qu'on
peut pas s'empêcher de faire une
comparaison entre ce que vous vivez le
film vous avez eu envie de faire ce film
à cause de l'histoire de Marie qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à faire
ce fil tout ce qui m'a amenéir
finalement c'est une moi j'aime bien je
me rends compte à travers les les trois
films que je je viens de faire et avec
César le le précédent ce qui m'intéresse
c'est c'est l'identité c'est qui on
est comment on peut se transformer
qu'est-ce qu'on peut devenir j'ai envie
de montrer
que on peut agir sur soi sur sa vie sur
son sur son identité ce qu'on peut faire
euh en face des autres si tout d'un coup
on réfléchit ou on va chercher dans son
inconscient des traumatises qui nous
handicape aller vers soi pour mieux
aller vers les autres exactement je
pense qu'il faut d'abord de psychanalyse
Richard Berry c'est combien d'années
j'ose pas si fa je sais pas une bonne
quinzaine d'années un peu plus un peu
plus ou oui toujours en psychanalyse euh
bah écoutez oui qu'est-ce que je fais
d'autes là
aveci on t on a tous une boîte noire on
a tous des secrets on a tous plein de
culpabilités pour des tas de choses
évidemment mais est-ce que vous c'est
une forme d'exorcisme parce que dans le
film donc ce qui ressort c'est qu'il n'a
pas pu dans cet accident qu'il a eu
jeune avec son frère il n'a pas pu
sauver son frère et il pense tout au
long de sa vie on va pas dévoiler le
film mais qu'il est coupable est-ce que
vous par l'acte que vous avez fait
vis-à-vis de votre sœur que vous avez
donc sauvé est-ce que je je n'ai pas
voulu écrire ce film par rapport à ça
d'ailleurs je vous le dis franchement je
n'y ai même pas pensé c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire
bien passionnant dans dans le dans dans
les principes de l'inconscient c'est que
moi j'ai écrit ce film pour parler de ce
que je viens de dire donc et puis au fur
et à mesure que le film était en train
de se terminer de s'écrire quelques
temps avant de le tourner j'ai pris
conscience que j'avais développé une
histoire qui n'est même pas dans la
nouvelle d'ailleurs ou la culabilité de
la nouvelle de Tonino benquista qui
s'appelle la boîte noire
et me suis servi vraiment du début hein
juste de du carnet noir et de de
l'accident après j'ai inventé toute tout
un tout un scénario toute une histoire
et je me suis rendu compte que c'était
effectivement quelque chose qui
rejoignait ma propre histoire comme quoi
je veux dire le principe de la boîte
noire et de l'inconscient est est vrai
quoi il y a quelque chose de réel
euh dans les obsessions qui ressortent
bah là sous la figure de ce personnage
qui se sent coupable de n'avoir pu SAU
son frère et qui finalement va découvrir
qu'il y avait quelqu'un d'autre qui
était coupable à sa voà qui n'est pas
responsable alors sans être indiscret
mais qu'est-ce qui vous pesait tant
qu'est-ce qui vous a conduit vous la
psychanalyse c'était un un mal de vie
finalement c'est ça doit être cette
forme de culpabilité mais je ne le
savais pas à l'époque moi c'était
simplement un mal de vivre une
difficulté à vivre et puis l'aventure a
été tellement passionnante que j'y ai
trouvé tellement d'autres choses
qu'après c'est du plaisir mais est-ce
que ça vous a vraiment permis de vous
libérer justement de cette culpabilité
d'avancer
par rapport à Marie en particulier ou
c'est ça que vous avez trouvé surt bien
sûr alors c'est c'est vous avec avec
Marie oui vous êtes tout petit habillé
par ma mère la main très protectrice
vous êtes l'aîné hein d'une famille de
trois enfants vous avez 18 mois de plus
que Marie c'est ça oui c'est ça
oui parce que en fait elle raconte d'ors
et déjà
l'histoire de notre vie quoi c'est je
j'ai un sentiment de protection de prise
en charge de responsabilité par rapport
à elle avec cette cravate ridicule qui
fait de moi un petit homme avant l'âge
c'est c'est mon histoire avec elle en
tout cas alors pour qu'on comprenne bien
aussi vos parents étaient étaient
commerçants donc au début ils ont pas
toujours été commerçants ils étaient
représentant pendant les premières
années de notre vie ils étaient
représentants jusqu'à l'âge de jusqu'à
ce que j'ai 5 ans à peu près il sur r
voilà c'est ça donc vous étiez on était
on nous laissait chez des
nourrices vous lesîné donc un peu chef
de fainé et voilà il me demandait de
donc de protéger ma sœur et j'ai essayé
de lui faire vivre une vie
entre guillemets normal enfin en tout
les cas qu'elle s'en approche et essayer
de faire en sorte qu'elle qu'elle puisse
continuer à continuer à voir ce que je
voyais à sortir là où je sortais à rire
comme je riais parce que je trouvais ça
profondément injuste qu'elle puisse pas
avoir droit à tout ça elle était si
belle
et capable de bouger ouais oui elle est
magnifique Marie on va VO magque moi
c'est marrant parce que je vous vois un
peu comme des jumeaux dans le fond vous
êtes un peu un couple gémellaire
peut-être oui peut-être qu'est-ce que
vous avez fait de plus fou par amour de
plus fou par amour bah c'est peut-être
ça mais moi je pense que tout ce qu'on
fait par amour c'est c'est pas fou c'est
c'est normal alors le 21 juin dernier
vous étiez côte à côte avec Marie à
l'hôpital et pendant qu'elle nous
rejoint on regarde ce portrait
d'elle Marie est la sœur cadette de
Richard Berry qu'il est né de trois
enfants dès son jeune âge on découvre
qu'elle souffre du syndrome d'alpore une
maladie génétique qui empêche chin de
fonctionner normalement c'était une
jeune femme une jeune fille qui se
cherchait qui était joyeuse et qui
voulait surtout pas qu'on lui dise
qu'elle était malade à l'adolescence son
état empire les greffes d'organes en
sont encore au stade expérimental
pourtant sa mère n'hésite pas au péril
de sa vie à offrir un Rin pour sauver sa
fille Marie a alors 17 ans j'ai reçu le
RIN de ma mère en 70 je l'ai gardé au
chaud dans mon ventre pendant 33 ans ce
qui est assez exceptionnel mais en 2002
son corps rejette la greffe commence
alors la attendre sous dialyse d'un
autre rein quand les médecins lui
diagnostiquent un cancer du sein très
étrangement
elle s'en fichait complètement du cancer
mais complètement elle n'en a jamais
parlé ce qu'elle voulait c'est de plus
aller en dialyse et qu'on lui greffein
et Sin c'est son frère Richard qui va le
lui donner le 21 juin 2005 mon frère m'a
sauvé la vie grâce à ce don d'organe
et une fois de plus je voudrais le
remercier et lui dire que je l'aime et
que ce geste me bouleverse toujours
autant merci Marie nous avoir rejoint
moi je suis très émue de voir côte à
côte vous avez toujours ce même
sentiment Marie d'avoir à dire merci à à
votre
frère pas qu'à mon frère à ma mère aussi
bien sûr mais je suis profondément
bouleversée par le geste qu'ils ont fait
tous les deux je sais qu'ils l'ont fait
naturellement
mais par rapport à ma maladie j'ai un
sentiment de culpabilité qui me lâche
pas vousimpression d'avoir accaparé
vraiment toute ma famille vampiriser ma
famille et ça c'est très dur très dur à
vivre à à quel moment l'un et l'autre
vous vous êtes rendu compte de ce
qu'avait fait votre mère parce que vous
étiez pe vous étiez assez jeune quand ça
s'est passé je peux vous dire que quand
vous voyez partir sur la table
d'opération un jour le 14 décembre
197 10 votre mère et votre sœur ça fait
un choc he quand
même c'est c'est moi j'ai tout de suite
pris conscience qu'il y avait une un
danger réel que vous pouviez les perdre
toutes les deux toutes les deux oui
surtout qu'à cette époque c'était moins
fréquent et moins répandu qu'aujourd'hui
il faut dire que c'est très très rare
dans les années 70 d'avoir une greffe
qui qui tienne aussi c'était
expérimental et qui tiennne pendant 33
ans mais on ne vous l'avait pas dit vous
un miracle j'ai appris très récemment
que mes parents et et mes frères le
savaient que j'étais menacé par le
rejet pendant ces 33 ans mais moi je ne
l'ai jamais su alors vous expliquez dans
le livre un livre très touchant que vous
publiez aux éditions Michel Laffond le
don de soi c'est un c'est un livre qui
raconte toute votre vie et qui va être
très très utile à des tas de à des tas
de personnes don vous avez fait la
préface he Richard et et vous dites que
vous avez attendu serein comme on
attendrait un enfant sauf qu'à l'inverse
de ce qui se passe habituellement cet
enfant-là va me donner la vie absolument
ouais ouais ouais et très
étrangement euh quand je parle de mon
rein j'ai tendance à porter la main sur
mon ventre parce qu'il est là devant et
que j'ai toujours eu le sentiment euh
d'avoir euh de porter comme un enfant en
moi ce que vous avez fait pendant donc
toutes ces années pendant 33 ans moi je
l'ai porté mon bébé mais c'est une
grossesse c'est une grossesse longue on
va sourire hein de tout ça mais vous
dites quelque chose qui me semble
tellement fort quand même Marie
j'imagine que Richard ça n'a pas pu lui
échapper c'est que vous dites dans le
fond que c'est plus naturel d'avoir la
vie donnée par sa mère donc
que d'avoir la vie donné par son frère
c'est ça que vous êtes en train de dire
tout à fait oui elle a raison je veux
dire c'est c'est c'est un acte qui
est qui est presque naturel de venant d'
d'une mère ou d'un père et qu' est
beaucoup moins venant de d'un frère mais
pour moi
c'était incontournable il fallait le
faire et donc voilà al Richard vous
étiez compatible he puisque ça a pu se
faire mais votre autre frère Philippe
qui c'était lui aussi hein voilà mon
frère s'était proposé tout de suite
Philip a tout de suite dit oui oui moi
aussi je pense que s'il avait été
compatible on se serait battu dis c'est
toi c'est moi et cetera et cetera mais
euh bon bah là les choses ont été
réglées très vite puisque lui il est pas
il a pas le même groupe sanguin donc
c'était on sa'est rien dit de plus
depuis hein non moi je suis très heureux
de l'avir vous dites dans la préface
qu'elle a retrouvé tout de suite son
teint oui le teint rose le lendemain
d'opération oui c'est vrai j'avais alors
qu'elle était cadaverie quoi elle était
plus irriguée et puis je veux dire elle
ne communiquait plus du tout quasiment
quoi tandis que là maintenant ça y est
regardez le livre est elle l'avait
commencé bien avant évidemment hein
pendant ses années de dialyse mais là
elle s'exprime il y a pas besoin d'en
dire plus hein ça ça voilà de toute
façon on a rien à se dire
donc mais vous avez quand même connais
pas cette
F alors c'est c'est vous avez lu
évidemment le le livre de Marie puisque
je disais vous vous en avez fait
d'ailleurs une très jolie
préface Marie explique que pendant c'est
ce temps d'attente à un moment donné
effectivement vous ne vous parliez plus
comment vous l'expliquez vous que vous
ne pouviez plus parler avec
Marie parce que comme je le disais tout
à l'heure cet échange là est au-delà des
mot quoi c'est pas
formulable et queles que soient les
choses qu'on pit pouvait se dire ça
n'arrivait pas à la hauteur de de la du
sentiment profond qui qui générait
justement tout ce qui était en train de
se passer et moi il fallait que je me me
démerde tout seul avec mes angoisses et
mes peurs qui étaient réelles et que je
je j'value encore même aujourd'hui et
puis elle il fallait qu'elle se démerde
avec sa culpabilité avec tout ça je veux
dire je pense qu'on avait chacun assez
de poids à supporter à à assumer donc
c'était inutile et et Marie vous aviez
peur pour lui mais j'avais beaucoup plus
peur pour lui que pour moi oui c'est
vrai bien sûr mais on sent Marie revient
quand même beaucoup he dans son livre
sur sentiment d'avoir été un poids pour
la famille que toute la famille se soit
organisée autour d'elle mais vous vous
avait dû aussi apporter des choses par
exemple à Richard bien sûr elle m'a elle
m'a offert la possibilité
de me dépasser finalement d'aller
d'aller au-delà de moi-même de
de d'être une d'être comme dit Patrick
d'ailleurs dans son film d'êt d'être
vraiment quelqu'un de
bien mais vous étiez quelqu'un de bien
oui mais là le fait de de ne pas pouvoir
contribuer à l'aider réellement j'étais
pas quelqu'un de bien totalement quoi il
fallait que je puisse faire quelque
chose monanément ça durera j que ça
durera je sais pas mais en tous les
cas de pouvoir l'aider à à vivre le
mieux possible ouais vous vous en avez
parlé de ça Marie parce que quand on on
sait que quand on reçoit effectivement
un organe la vue il y a le rejet
possible on sa donc c'est pas la peine
de d'en parler mais en revanche moi j'ai
cette hâte de vivre de de faire des
choses
et je j'ai j'ai conscience que
H j'ai pas de temps à perdre quoi HM
j'en profite d'ailleurs hein pour donner
des chiffres c'est important donc en
France on est très très en retard il y a
5 % mais vous pouvez peut-être le dire
vous Richard parce que je sais que c'est
devenu un combat pour l'née 6 % et là
c'est en train de monter cette année euh
on va peut-être passer à 7 cette année %
de personne donc en bonne santé de
donneur vivant hein de donneur vivant ça
veut dire que sur l'ensemble des greffes
voilà
il n'y a que on fait que 6 % de donheurs
vivant alors que par exemple en
Norvège au ÉtatsUnis 40 % 40 % doncme
énorme oui oui donc c'est la peur ça
veut dire que c'est la peur qui c'est
pas la peur c'est pas la peur je pense
que c'est un manque
d'informmation parce que les je pense
que les gens ont cette générosité mais
ils ne savent pas comment s'y prendre
comment faire personne ne leur
explique les démarches personne alors
l'un et l'autre vous êtes memre de
l'association laerg l'erg l'association
pour l'information et la recherche sur
les maladies rénales et et on apprend
aussi dans dans le livre que il ne vous
l'avait pas dit votre frère ben oui il
avait fait les cavaliers seul une fois
de
plus et donc vous ne parlez pas vous
êtes très secret oui moi je c'est vrai
on le reproche très souvent parle pas il
agit on le voit on le voit comme par
exemple c'est je me suis rendu compte
que j'avais rendez-vous au ministère de
la Santé pour faire avancer justement
les choses de la du don d'organ et je je
je lui ai dit le jour même je
crois c'est assez énervant quand
même mais mais ça ça ça vous a fait
plaisir ah oui ça m'a fait énormément
plaisir pas seulement pour moi mais pour
tous les malades qui qui sont en attente
bien sûr le numéro de l'association
s'inscrit d'ailleurs he en ce moment sur
sur l'écran et Richard vous avez vous
avez continué vous donc dans ce combat
puisque vous vous êtes en en pass
d'obtenir que ceux qui sont donneur
d'organ se soi inscrit sur les les
cartes d'identité les per conduire c'est
vous qui l'avez oui je je je me bat
beaucoup pour ça déjà parce que vous
savez la loi française a est très bien
faite en la matière il faut savoir
reconnaître ça c'estàd qu'en fin de
compte tout le monde est donneur donneur
potentiel sauf si on se déclare on se
manifeste comme n'étant pas d'honneur
mais malgré cette loi la médecine les
médecins demandent toujours parontologie
à la famille si on est d'accord s'ils
sont d'accord pour qu'on prélève un
organe quel qu'il soit sur quelqu'un qui
est
mort oui voilà d'une mort cérébrale et
dans 30 plus de 30 % des cas
oui facile oui oui il refuse mais
c'estàd
que qui est totalement compréhensible et
même je veux dire humain quoi donc moi
moi je pense que si on on on déterminait
tout simplement sur la carte d'identité
ou sur le permis de conduire qu'on est
d'honneur ou pas il y aurait plus cette
question là à poser et ça simplifierait
le travail de la médecine comme des gens
concernés des familles s cela dit il
faut dire aussi qu'en attendant hein
quand on est donneur quand on on peut
l'inscrire soi-même on l'a dans son sac
à main on pres a voilà on informer ses
proches et ça ça facilite les choses
c'est important de le rappeler répéter
parce que on sauve on sauve énormément
de vie
bien pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne
in mire dum abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche